I think rule one of Barbie land is you
just always have the right outfit on
Jacqueline Duran obviously an incredibly
decorated award-winning costume designer
and has worked with Greta before it's
quite difficult to know how to approach
this because the character is Barbie and
Barbie can be anything
[Music]
can represent any person any profession
anything especially in this film
costumes are everything I mean unless
you're dressed for it you're not doing
it if there's a meme out right now that
says the caution designer for Barbie has
a free pass to happen
I agree
[Music]
the main thing that separates Barbies
from humans is that every time you see a
Barbie she's fully dressed for a purpose
and one thing that really helped was
having big details like big buttons big
earrings big necklaces and there's
something about the big chunkiness that
made her look more doll-like here I go
each of the actresses would choose
something that would be expressive of
their character in a way what we're
talking about is how you would want to
represent yourself as a woman so each
person needed to have an input in what
that would be